Fox host Neil Cavuto has not been
playing up Donald Trump's promotion of
hydroxychloroquine he's not stopped
short of going after Trump for his
absolutely ridiculous musings about
bleach injections and now after Donald
Trump has asserted that he is taking
prophylactic hydroxychloroquine to
protect himself from coronavirus Neil
Cavuto is saying this will kill you if
you have certain comorbidities let's
listen to the start of Neil Cavuto
segment about this yesterday that was
stunning the president's just
acknowledged that he is taking
aggressive chloroquine a drug that meant
really to treat malaria and lupus the
president's insisted that has enormous
benefits for patients so either trying
to prevent or already have a code 19 the
fact of the matter is though when the
president said what have you got to lose
in the number of studies those certainly
vulnerable the population have one thing
to lose their lives then Cavuto going in
even harder a little bit later on in the
segment saying this will kill you in
certain situations the VA study to which
the president alluded wasn't a loaded
political one it was a test on patients
there and those who took it in a
vulnerable population including those
with respiratory or other conditions
they died I want to stress again they
died if you are in a risky population
here and you were taking this as a
preventive treatment to ward off the
virus or in a worst case scenario you
are dealing with the virus and you are
in this vulnerable population it will
kill you I cannot stress enough this
will kill you
so listen Neil Cavuto is horrible Neil
Cavuto has been spreading disinformation
on Fox News for decades this is not any
kind of praise of Neil Cavuto
journalistic skills or credentials in
any way but Cavuto is right about this
maybe he knows Fox News has a
disproportionately older audience Cavuto
is saying the right thing and he's now
in hot water with the virulent trumpets
who are calling for his firing now one
thing that from
said didn't look so good was that one VA
study that says hydroxychloroquine
doesn't seem to work the tree
coronavirus it is a good thing that neil
cavuto pointed out that's a good study
in fact we have a lot of different
studies on hydroxychloroquine that's
probably the best randomly controlled
randomized controlled trial with a
placebo group and it was a blinded study
so good good that Neil Cavuto is doing
this meanwhile Sean Hannity and Laura
Ingraham and others on Fox News have
been gleefully promoting this drug and
it's completely dystopian we have Fox
News hosts arguing with each other over
which drugs people should be taking
rather than leaving it to the doctors
here's Laura Ingraham bringing on a
guest last night who says we should be
thrilled that Donald Trump is taking
this because he's brilliant check out
this wacky woman doctor Evette Lozano
doctor Lozano people on television news
anchors guess or freaking out about this
what about this should we the American
people know is that irresponsible of him
to be taking hydroxychloroquine and why
do they care I think the people of the
United States need to know that they
have a brilliant President of the United
States and that he wants to keep himself
safe and healthy so that he can guide us
through this pandemic he's done an
incredible job he is saving thousands
and thousands of lives and I commend him
for coming out publicly and sharing with
his people that he is taking this drug
that it is completely safe and that
doctors need to start prescribing it
immediately of course it's not
completely safe and just a reminder I
have no idea logical opposition to
hydroxychloroquine working they are
promoting this as a miracle drug and
that is not based in fact last thing is
this entire hydroxychloroquine thing
from yesterday a distraction from the
number of coronavirus deaths from Trump
firing his fourth Inspector General in a
few weeks we are still covering all of
those stories but other media outlets
are spending a lot of time on this
instead of some of those stories
it could be once again one of trumps
planted distractions we'll have more
cover of coverage of this on the David
Pakman show instagram page at david
pakman show follow us there I'll be
right back one of our sponsors today is
VIN Chara watches giving you 15% off
your entire order when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch don't pay
thousands of dollars for a high-quality
watch that looks great because you don't
have to all of in Cera's watches are
made with high-end materials masterfully
built and they look like something you'd
spend a ton of money on but ever even
chera watch ranges from about a hundred
and fifty to three hundred bucks I went
over to their website and picked out the
bellwether in silver and white really
nice elegant look and a lot of people
ask me where's the watch from really
really great look totally different they
also sent me the altitude in matte black
and red a much more rugged view of what
a watch can look like really liked it as
well as well as the athletic strap it's
a new year it's a new decade it's time
to re-establish your style add something
new to your look and a high-quality
watch is the perfect way to do that
you can get 15% off inch arrows entire
collection when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch